Канцлер Німеччини відвідує навчання українських військових на базі в Путлосі на півночі Німеччини.
Українців навчають керувати зенітними самохідними установками "Гепард".
У відеозверненні, адресованому українцям з нагоди Дня незалежності,
канцлер Німеччини Олаф Шольц запевнив у подальшій підтримці України зброєю.
Ми продовжимо постачання зброї - від самохідних гаубиць до зенітних ракетних комплексів. Місяць за місяцем.
Днями Шольц пообіцяв Києву постачання озброєнь вартістю понад 500 млн євро.
У новому пакеті йдеться про додаткові системи ППО Iris-T, броньовані евакуаційні машини, ракетні установки,
високоточні боєприпаси та засоби захисту від дронів.
Ці поставки заплановані на 2023 рік, лише в окремих випадках йдеться про цей рік.
При цьому буквально минулого тижня німецька газета Die Welt повідомила, що, за її даними, уряд ФРН
останніми тижнями ігнорує прохання України щодо подальших поставок озброєнь.
Знайти офіційні дані про те, яку зброю Німеччина постачає Україні, можна на сайті федерального уряду.
Тут також є список того озброєння, яке планується надати.
У Німеччині, судячи з публікацій у ЗМІ, активно стежать за цим переліком.
Так, приміром, появу в ньому високоточних артилерійських снарядів Vulcano активно коментували на початку цього тижня.
Керовані високоточні снаряди для самохідних броньованих гаубиць
відкривають для українців нові можливості на полі бою, пише німецька газета Die Welt.
І все ж, критика на адресу Німеччини щодо того, що військової підтримки недостатньо і вона надто повільна, не вщухає.
Так, Андрій Мельник, який незабаром залишає свою посаду посла України в Німеччині,
в інтерв'ю DW подякував Берліну за надану допомогу, але додав, що, як і раніше, вважає цю допомогу недостатньою.
Ми закликаємо німецький уряд допомогти нам справді усім, чим тільки можна, вийти за межі того, на що може піти Бундесвер,
щоб надати Україні найсучасніші озброєння.
Адже цю війну можна зупинити лише на полі бою,
бо лише таким чином Путіна можна повернути до здорового ґлузду,
і лише завдяки цьому з'явиться реальний шанс для миру.
Без цієї військової допомоги, яка лише по краплині надходить - це ніби гра в кішки-мишки все ще для нас.
Тобто ми трохи просунулися, але того, що ми отримуємо від Німеччини, все ще недостатньо.
Німеччина може зробити значно більше.
Подібну критику на адресу ФРН висловлюють і в інших країнах.
Головна теза: Німеччина - найбільша економіка в Європі і має взяти на себе роль лідера у підтримці України.
Я розчарований тим, що Німеччина не надала більше.
Я розумію причину, але думаю, що якби Берлін хотів надати більше, він міг би це зробити.
Німеччина має бути якщо не лідером, то одним із лідерів у Європі.
Але щоб бути реальним лідером, якого всі поважають за його моральний авторитет,
а також за його економічну міць та решту доброго, що є в Німеччині,
Німеччина має розглядатися як активний помічник України в її перемозі над Росією.
Дискусія про обсяги та темпи поставок озброєнь точиться і в самій Німеччині.
Днями три депутати Бундестагу, експерти з питань оборони від правлячих у ФРН партій соціал-демократів,
зелених і вільних демократів у спільній статті для німецького видання Der Spiegel
закликали уряд Німеччини збільшити постачання зброї Україні,
навіть якщо це тимчасово може послабити боєздатність Бундесверу.
Автори статті зазначають, що досі уряд пояснював порівняно невеликі обсяги військової допомоги Україні
дефіцитом техніки у самому Бундесвері.
"Це ніщо інше як сконструйований конфлікт цілей, оскільки безпеку та стабільність Європи наразі захищають в Україні", - зазначили вони.
Контраргумент у відповідь - це насамперед недостатні потужності німецького ВПК,
які постійно скорочувалися після возз'єднання Німеччини.
Наша величезна проблема - це промислова проблема.
Навіть якщо ми й хотіли би поставити більше самохідних гаубиць, наприклад, для надання адресної допомоги,
ми бачимо, що промислові потужності не дозволяють нам цього зробити…
Це величезна дилема, бо ми маємо порожні склади і ми не можемо поповнити запаси.
Тому ми сподіваємося, що інші союзники, такі як США, зможуть надати більш дієву допомогу, швидше поповнюючи запаси.
Німецький військовий аналітик Вольфґанґ Ріхтер також вказує на те,
що військова промисловість ФРН не працює у режимі воєнного часу.
На його думку, Німеччина наразі постачає те, що вона в змозі поставити.
Він закликає також не забувати про технічну складову при знятті такого озброєння зі зберігання.
Якщо ви знімаєте такі системи озброєнь зі зберігання, то їх потрібно привести до ладу,
адже вони не просто так були зняті з озброєння.
Вони були виведені з експлуатації, оскільки були не потрібні Бундесверу і тому не обслуговувалися.
І, відповідно, вже немає логістичного ланцюжка, який забезпечує їхню роботу.
Це стосується запчастин, але значною мірою це стосується боєприпасів.
Якщо ви хочете привести все це в норму, знадобиться час.
Проте в Німеччині існує політичний консенсус щодо необхідності військової підтримки України,
причому стільки, скільки це буде необхідно.
А це кардинальна метаморфоза, якщо порівнювати з позицією Берліна пів року тому, на початку війни.
Минулими вихідними очільниця німецького МЗС Анналена Бербок заявила,
що оскільки наразі неможливо домогтися закінчення війни шляхом переговорів,
то в Німеччини є вибір: або нічого не робити, або "ми говоримо, що підтримуємо (Україну) у військовому плані,
аби припинити подальше просування росіян".
У такій ситуації Бербок вважає військову підтримку українців єдиним шляхом, яким може йти Німеччина.
"Як би жахливо це не було", - додала міністерка від Зелених, відомих своїми глибоко пацифістськими традиціями.
У тому, що саме від поставок західного озброєння ЗСУ залежить здатність України
контратакувати та відвойовувати окуповані РФ території, не сумніваються ані в Києві, ані на Заході.
Попри численні прорахунки на початку повномасштабного вторгнення,
російським військам вдалося захопити значні території на півдні України, створивши наземний коридор до Криму.
Контрнаступ української армії в районі Херсона, про який так багато говорили останнім часом, сповільнився.
Експерти дедалі частіше говорять про затяжний позиційний конфлікт, тривалість якого непрогнозована.
Що ще також треба мати на увазі - то це настання пори року, коли земля замерзає.
Це дасть змогу йти в атаку широким фронтом. Чим і займеться в цій ситуації Росія, а щодо України…
Гадаю, багато залежатиме від того, чи вийде в України знизити російську вогневу міць,
зокрема й за допомогою західних систем озброєнь.
Експерти зазначають, що вкрай важливу роль відіграє також розвідка західних країн -
союзники забезпечують Україну максимально докладними розвідданими,
які дозволяють ефективно використовувати високоточну зброю.
Це основа для точкових ударів, але не масштабного контрнаступу.
Половина Донецької області, як і раніше, перебуває не під контролем Росії.
Вони зараз намагаються зробити там прорив, щоб просунутися у бік Слов'янська і Краматорська.
Але це просування йде лише метр за метром, оскільки Україна вперто чинить опір.
Обидві сторони зазнають суттєвих втрат у живій силі та техніці.
А на південному заході в районі Херсона ситуація, схоже, така, що українська армія готує наступ
ударами вглиб російських позицій - руйнуючи мости, склади боєприпасів і навіть аеродроми.
З іншого боку, одними такими ударами ситуацію не переломити - треба відвойовувати території.
Але для цього українцям треба сконцентрувати свої сили, яких у них у такій формі може й не виявитися.
Німецькі експерти вважають, що ця війна не закінчиться розгромною поразкою
однієї сторони та беззаперечною перемогою іншої.
У своїх прогнозах вони схиляються до сценарію, за якого втрати обох сторін досягнуть рівня,
який рано чи пізно підштовхне їх до переговорів.
Інші вказують на необхідність посилити поставки західної зброї і вважають,
що до кінця року російська армія буде остаточно виснажена.